[Music]
and who's your Debbie News lose your
patter submit about what hell a team
found out her dad was a murderer after
researching a school project online oh
that's badass your family murderers
alright so think about it we're adults
right of course murder is bad
whatever pins on how you murder we all
know that there's a difference yeah when
you're a kid and you find out your
parents kill people you're like oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] cool my parents are a
[ __ ] gangster would you feel the same
way if you found out your father had
killed two little ten-year-old girls no
my dad killed a seven-foot rapist that
was trying to invade our town and [ __ ]
all the women in our [ __ ]
village then he's a badass but if it was
like my dad is a molester and he [ __ ]
kills everybody that he molest that's
weird he's not that cool yeah the cool
factor what you don't want to bring your
gang in on a bigger parent Cindy none of
that show and tell this is what my daddy
does oh my god with a show too with the
[ __ ] diagram and you open it up in
all the pictures
it's a chalkboard [ __ ] lighting out
on the floor that's dark it's really
dark so Samantha she's now 18 years old
when she was 14 years old she found out
about her father's identity when she
went to her citizenship class and so in
that class teacher handed out names of
serial killers or murderers of that area
and where she lives and so she got this
name Ian Huntley and so she didn't
really think much of it she didn't know
who this person was she wasn't like
that's my bad a name she never knew
because growing up
her mom left him when she was still
pregnant with Samantha so she didn't
really know him and when he committed
these murders she was four years old so
she didn't even know anything about I
mean growing up the mom always said your
dad is a very bad man that did something
very bad to two little girls that's all
the mom would would tell her so she
didn't really know much as she really
cares for the mom [ __ ] up you got to
give him the treatment your dad [ __ ]
murdered all these a nice I'm your
mother I must send you back to him so
you know the truth because if you're a
little girl your parent tells you your
dad does really bad things either you're
gonna think oh my dad's a freakin spanks
my mom you don't want to confuse the
kids she at least she was being truthful
she wasn't trying to hide anything but
she just didn't want to tell her the
whole thing she don't want to get
traumatized not so much I used to crawl
into my parents bed and I'll see my mom
naked why are you naked in my mom like
your dad is so bad he always takes but
clothes off so she tells me she tells me
that my dad is a bad person I'm like
taking the calls on forgetten instead of
knowing oh he's killing me true that
some of the truth cuz what what do kids
know bad is like bad grades like oh my
daddy got bad grades grades oh man
that's why my mama left him I was
thinking in this story that this girl
was living with their father the whole
time is she had no idea he was repeated
yeah so then that's why she finally
discovered because and the reason why
she even discovered this is when she was
searching this guy's name she came
across a lot of pictures on google and
she came across this one photo of her
and her mother and then she was like why
like why am I even involved in this
search and then that's when like she
looked into it some more she discovered
that that was her father like this bad
man that did something bad to two little
girls was her own father so she was just
like shocked and she was just she was
just crying she was crying so much as
she went salute Oh get over and you
never met this dude she was crying
because she I mean imagine if you find
out like your father is such a horrible
person because apparently he beat her
mom just
yes you Huebsch Oktar in the stomach
trying to get her to heaven miscarriage
that's crazy yeah like she that's worse
than David trying to bucket punch G on
his stomach I know I've said multiple
times but she's awake she's like crazy
uh yeah and then I apparently he's like
a mega pedophile cuz at that time
Samantha's mom was fifteen when he was
like 24
what's a mega pedophile mega pedophile
he continually had a lot of
relationships with girls as young as 11
when he was like already and that's like
Elvis Presley why is that okay how the
[ __ ] is this guy still getting [ __ ]
weighs me in prison so yeah he's in
prison now so this is the mental what I
don't understand is that like he's a
crazy pedophile murderer right and he's
still getting ladies well he was getting
ladies before he murdered he's grown it
was hurt with Samantha's mom of age she
was 15
oh okay so he he was a pedophile and he
impregnated her yeah how old is she here
like twenty-something she's 18 now oh
she's a party yeah so this is her father
what he's still alive no that's what he
looked like before it like when he
murdered the girl he's she's so young he
doesn't even look like a pedophile yeah
so it's crazy so humans actually a
caretaker at the school of where these
two girls went oh two ten-year-old girls
and so apparently these girls they were
walking down the street on their way to
somewhere and he stopped them on the
street and told them that his girlfriend
which also worked at the school was home
which she wasn't she was somewhere else
he told these girls they all come in
like no so once I was here - so then I
guess the girls walked in I don't know
what exactly happened but within the
hour both of the girls we're good she
had a girlfriend like really had a
girlfriend at that time yeah he had a
girlfriend that was not underage no she
would do this see this is this is what
I'm wondering like all the [ __ ] do they
have so many girlfriends that guy is
greedy like if you're a pedophile just
stick with that age group don't be
coming into my age group taking my girls
that's right go stick to one don't come
and [ __ ] take away the fish in there
awaiting everybody they're a real threat
to you and you're married you have I'm
talking about half of that the Hollywood
Life that's right I don't know the
Hollywood Life I only know the Monterey
Park life should it's so innocent he
just looks like how did he turn Latino
he's white here and then he turned
Latino no that's him honestly dude he
looks like he's a cast member of Boy
Meets World or something yeah like he's
like Peter Matthews like one of the
missing brothers who cut the mom's banks
Oh for real don't let him grow up so are
you a pedophile if you're 17 in your
girlfriend's 16 nope are you a pedophile
if you're 14 in your girlfriend's 13
nope but if your tastes are never change
that's what makes you a pedophile yep oh
you're always a Texas girl does that say
like we all are attracted to 13 year
olds when were 13 right yep then are we
just stay attracted to 13 year olds up
until we're 60 you know I was hella
horny for eight-year-olds at one point
when you were 8 good I never was that's
petal foolish never I was always trying
to 5 20 year olds yep I was trying to
get back in the [ __ ] I was like girl
you ain't got no titties these are the
two girls that's messed up man
motor phone that's the videophone
company isn't it madness some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I don't like that I don't
ah man this guy's because when they were
so like when these two girls went
missing
the entire town was just like you know
like shocked like oh my gosh what a
small safe town right yeah it is so then
that's when he got actually really
involved with he did interviews let me
investigate I'm gonna help ya he was
just saying like I did see the girls
pass by my he's trying to cover it up
yeah exactly good on mafia we should
bring him in so once he they discovered
evidence and like just everything linked
back to him they were like okay for sure
he was on that
kill these girls then they also jailed
the girlfriend because the girlfriend
when she was being interviewed
she gave a false alibi for him saying
that's me there's no way he could have
done that so then she also wanted to go
for that but as of now like she changed
her name and she's hiding because she's
a if I never met my father and I found
out he was a rapist I don't know if it
would faze me cuz I don't know him I
don't know the [ __ ] the thing
that was really like psychologically
damaged it mom got beat up by him it's
because she kept saying like is any part
of him of this like monster in me yeah I
mean if you're if you're walking around
and you don't want a bone little kids
then you're good is there a pedophile
gene yes I'd like a rapist gee uh
because what if her kid becomes a
pedophile
like the the [ __ ] up mentalities like
what she's scared that I completely
understand I just want her to know you
cou don't trip don't worry girl and what
if one day we find out that the
pedophile gene is natural that's true
did you hear of like people that
sometime they're just like I can't
control you I don't know why you're just
there you see old ass dog something
puppy sometimes let's hope they never
like expose that so what if it's what if
it's natural then instead of treating
them like a criminal maybe they need to
be like psychologically rehab yeah I
remember we talked about that Jacob you
sorry where were these special like
dolls made for these pedophiles to like
get their fantasies out on these dolls
that are really not the same Nami like
you can't give me a [ __ ] like bag of
[ __ ] and be like here [ __ ] this Joe not
the same I'm not a pedophile I'm just
saying it's not the same as a woman in
that kind of context in comparison but
anyway yeah doesn't work you got two
life sentences he's gonna be in jail
for two lives so even if he was a cat he
only used up to the girlfriend got three
and a half years
um but yeah recently though he was in
the music because there was an inmate
that tried to kill him so he got his
throat slashed nice oh yeah they hate
rapists in there yeah they don't like
kid rapists I've had a few this man a
trophy for slashing his throat well
that's what happens though cuz they
picture their kids yeah you want I have
a ten-year-old daughter you [ __ ]
killed a ten-year-old girl guess what
I'm killing you I love justice hello JK
friends now if you haven't subscribed to
our videos you know what to do hit that
subscribe button I'll suck your dick
[Music]